high performance liquid chromatography  is a frequently used technique in  industrial biochemistry  in this technique the annihilate in is  passed with the solvent through a  chromatographic column under very high  pressure  in this case you have a sample injector  through which the sample is injected  there is a degasser and pump which  channels the fluid through a column  under very high pressure it passes  through a detector where the detection  happens so when the flow stream passes  through the detector there is a  particular Way by which the detector can  detect the overall annihilate there are  many advantages of this technique  including High resolving power speed  reproducibility automated sampling and  there are columns which can be reused  but there this is very expensive  technique and that's the disadvantage  subscribe for more